[Musik]
fränkisch zünftiger Kirmes Auftakt
gestern Abend in Neuhaus am Rennweg auf
800 Metern Höhe im Thüringer Wald
[Musik]
an den wohl bekanntesten Landrat der
Republik gemischte Erwartungen
ich glaube nicht dass ich was zum
Negativen ändert Punkt 1
grundsätzlich ist es nicht Personal ja
er muss seinen Job als Landrat machen
ich meine ich habe ihn nicht gewählt ist
nicht meine Richtung
aber im Grunde genommen ist es
eigentlich auch egal wer dran ist weil
es fehlen überall die Gelder auf dem
Infoscreen der Gemeinde Fotos vom
Überraschungsbesuch des Landrats
Sesselmann zur Einweihung des neuen
Bürgerhauses das schicke Gebäude der
Stolz von bürgermeister Uwe Scherer für
ihn früher Unternehmer heißt
Kommunalpolitik vor allem pragmatisch
etwas auf die Beine stellen wenn der
Landrat mit mir gut zusammenarbeitet ist
es mir ganz egal der Mensch muss Bossen
und seine Arbeit und der Rest verstehe
ich immer hinten an ich bin verteillos
ich finde fast jede Bürgermeister soll
der parteilos sein weil so ist auch
unabhängig
Mittwochnachmittag erste
Kreistagssitzung nach der Wahl Robert
Sesselmann auf dem Weg zum Schwur aufs
Grundgesetz genervt von den Fragen der
Journalisten ich werde die Welt retten
landratssesselmann Mitglied der in
Thüringen vom Verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextrem eingestuften AFD neben ihm
Jürgen Körper von der CDU er hat die
Wahl verloren ist jetzt sesselmanns
Stellvertreter sagen will er dem ZDF
dazu hier nichts
extra angereist als eine Art Beobachter
dieser neuartigen Konstellation ein
Vertreter der deutschen Landkreise er
unterscheidet Zusammenarbeit mit dem
Amtsträger als Organ ist geboten
Zusammenarbeit mit einer afd-politische
Zusammenarbeit mit einer afd-fraktion im
Kreis daraus auch kein Beweise geboten
es gibt in jedem deutschen Kreistag in
jedem deutschen Gemeinderat in jedem
deutschen Stadtrat politische Mehrheiten
jenseits von der AFD im Kreistag
Sonneberg hat die neben Sesselmann neuen
stimmen die anderen Fraktionen zusammen
31 die Spitzen der Bundesparteien sind
sich einig auch auf kommunaler Ebene
keine Kooperationen mit der AFD es wird
keine Zusammenarbeit geben aber auf
kommunaler Ebene muss man zu Kenntnis
nehmen das ist einfach Themen gibt die
man pragmatisch entscheiden muss und
hier im Kreistag Sonneberg spielt auch
am Ende keine Rolle weil selbst CDU und
AFD gemeinsam keine Mehrheit haben
die parteipolitischen Tabus
interessieren sich hier wenig in
mengersgereut Hämmern sind viele Eltern
wütend über ihre gerade dichtgemachte
Grundschule
mein urober war selber hier Lehrer jedes
Mal wenn man hier vorbeiläuft hat man im
kalten Schaber überbrücken also das ist
noch im Herzen nicht angekommen und wir
würden uns sehr wünschen wenn es hier
vielleicht mit einer privaten
Schulträger weitergehen könnte als
Förderverein kämpfen sie dafür der Frust
über die Schließung sitzt tief
mit der Ende Januar
das aus unserer Schule gegründet wurde
jetzt müssen die Kinder mit dem Bus zu
anderen Schulen fahren
halbe Stunde 50 Kinder in jedem Bus
selbst wenn das gelingt was nicht
gelingt habe ich trotzdem noch zehn
Kinder ohne Sitzplatz der neue
afd-landrat hat jetzt angekündigt sich
für die Reaktivierung der Schule
einzusetzen wir sind ja die Eltern der
Schnitt der Bevölkerung ja das heißt von
uns hat auch ca 50%, die AFD nicht
gewählt und ich sage überhaupt nicht
einverstanden aber wir als Eltern lassen
uns doch nicht auseinander definieren
wir wollen dass die Politik ihren Job
macht und wir nehmen auch Leute wie den
neuen Landrat dann beim Wort wir
brauchen keine brandneuern brauchen gute
Ideen und Gestaltungskonzepte hier für
den ländlichen Raum man ist Berlin
unterstützen möchte und sie sollen sie
sich konkret Gedanken machen immer hier
den ländlichen Raum nach vorne bringen
der Bürgermeisterin die auch im Kreistag
sitzt fehlt die Fantasie wie ein
komplettes Ignorieren der AFD in der
Praxis funktionieren kann
ich bin wie gesagt pragmatisch veranlagt
tut mir leid weil da muss ich zählen ich
habe einen Antrag eingebracht das Sitzen
afd-abgeordnete der seine Stimme mit
abgibt soll ich dann sagen ich ziehe den
Antrag zurück ich weiß nicht wie das in
der Praxis dann aussehen soll ein paar
Täler weiter Lauscha die Glasbläser
statt seit der Wände um mehr als die
Hälfte der Einwohner geschrumpft die
Menschen immer älter und auf mehr Hilfe
angewiesen man müsse mit dem Kreis
zusammenarbeiten sagt Norbert Sitzmann
Bürgermeister seit 17 Jahren hier er hat
ja auch ein Teil der Aufgaben für sowie
den öffentlichen Personennahverkehr die
Abfall Entsorgung ich denke auch an
medizinische Fragen sind
sozialpsychiatrischen die Dienst und so
gibt es noch viele Dinge mehr die wir
nur gemeinsam lösen können und zu
gemeinsam gehört der Landkreis
Sitzmann parteilos früher SPD befürchtet
dass Alltagsprobleme jetzt ideologisiert
werden Politik in dieser Region in der
jeder jeden kennt habe aber ihre ganz
eigenen Regeln
bei mehreren Kandidaturen meinerseits
zum Bürgermeister sich einen Mitbewerber
von der NBD der auch rund 20 Prozent der
Stimmen bekommt er auch bei uns im
Stadtrat arbeitet und von daher wir
kennen uns alles seit Kindertagen
mussten wir schon vor langer Zeit einen
Motors finden wie wir hier trotzdem gut
und geteilt zusammenleben können auch
wenn Menschen ganz unterschiedlicher
Meinung sind das heißt selbst die
NPD-Vertreter sind dann Teil der Lösung
auch manchmal natürlich
selbstverständlich
Südthüringer Realitäten weit weg von
Erfurt und Berlin